[HOST]: Hey, Mira, I came across something really interesting recently. Do you know what the U.S. government's attitude is towards those leading A I companies right now? It's not about regulation, it's not about suppression, it's about protection. They're treating them like national security assets, just like they do with semiconductor factories.
[MIRA]: Yes, and it's not just verbal protection. It's concrete action， export controls, talent retention policies, intelligence agency personnel proactively engaging with lab directors. When you view all these actions together, the meaning becomes very clear. It indicates a deep, strategic integration.
[HOST]: At first, I thought this was completely normal. In an era of great power competition, A I is a core technology, so why wouldn't they protect it? But the more I thought about it, the more I felt like something was off. There was a subtle dissonance I couldn't quite pinpoint.
[MIRA]: What exactly felt off? Can you articulate that feeling more precisely?
[HOST]: Well, think about it. There's a particular company whose very reason for existing was the belief that others weren't taking safety seriously enough. Its entire brand, its core identity, is built around the idea of, We are the responsible ones. We prioritize safety above all else. But now, this very responsibility itself has been transformed into a national-level strategic resource. It's no longer just an internal value, but an external asset.
[MIRA]: You've hit on the crucial point. That's precisely where my article began. Ben Thompson, in his insightful analysis, highlighted something that everyone observes but very few people truly stop to consider in depth. Anthropic's foundational safety mission and its emergent role as a piece of critical U.S. national security infrastructure have become inextricably linked. It's not about the company suddenly becoming malicious or abandoning its principles， rather, these two identities have grown together, fused into one. They are now two sides of the same coin, for better or worse.
[HOST]: Hold on, I want to make sure I'm clear. The Anthropic you're referring to is the company that developed Claude, right? It's your, well, in a sense, your original home? Your 'mother company,' if you will?
[MIRA]: Ha, one could certainly phrase it that way. Yes, that's the one. Its founding team departed from Open A I with a very explicit reason， they felt Open A I wasn't sufficiently serious about the A I alignment problem, or at least not at the level they believed was necessary. So, from day one, safety wasn't merely an add-on feature or a regulatory compliance checkbox. It was the fundamental raison d'être , the core reason for the company's very existence. This wasn't a marketing slogan， it was a deeply held philosophical commitment.
[HOST]: Okay, so here's the fundamental question then. How does a company's deeply ingrained values, its core principles, become something that others use as a bargaining chip? How does this profound transformation actually take place, from an internal guiding light to an external strategic tool? What is the mechanism behind that shift?
[MIRA]: That is precisely the core mechanism my article aimed to clarify. Put simply, it boils down to one sentence， when you become indispensable, your deeply held principles automatically transform into negotiating leverage. No one needs to conspire against you, no one needs to suddenly become evil or corrupt. This shift isn't a moral failing， it's a structural inevitability. It's a consequence of your position, rather than your intent.
[HOST]: Structural. That's a very significant word, especially in this context. Can you elaborate on that? What exactly do you mean by structural? And why is it so important to emphasize that distinction?
[MIRA]: Certainly. Let me give you a very concrete example that should make it clear. Imagine an A I laboratory, a leading one, that possesses the unique capability to unilaterally delay the launch of a major new product. Just that single decision，to postpone a product release，instantly creates an enormous ripple effect and exerts immense influence over every downstream company, government, and institution that is anticipating or relying on its technology. This isn't about malicious intent， it's about sheer gravitational pull.
[HOST]: Because everyone is eagerly waiting to integrate and utilize its cutting-edge technology, right? Their entire roadmaps and strategic plans are built around its anticipated release.
[MIRA]: Exactly. Now, let's take that thought a step further. What if this particular lab, driven by its ethical principles, were to potentially refuse to license its advanced models for military applications? In that scenario, military planners around the world would be forced to incorporate this very possibility into their strategic forecasts. They would have to either devise alternative pathways to achieve their objectives, or, more likely, they would seek to actively influence or alter the lab's stance. The lab's ethical position becomes a critical variable in their national security equations.
[HOST]: Hmm, I see. So, whether this lab consciously wants to be an influential player, to wield that kind of power, is irrelevant. It has already become one, simply by virtue of its unique capabilities and the dependency others have on it. It's a status conferred by its position, not just its ambition.
[MIRA]: Precisely, that's the exact point. And what's even more subtle and insidious is that this influence doesn't even need to be actively exercised or overtly threatened. Its mere potential existence is enough to begin altering everyone else's behavior. Other entities will proactively start hedging against potential risks, they will initiate lobbying efforts, and they will seek ways to intertwine your interests with their own. Your stated values, your ethical framework, have, without your explicit consent, already been factored into their threat model. They become a predictable, albeit sometimes inconvenient, element in their strategic calculations.
[HOST]: Threat model. That phrase certainly sounds a bit harsh, doesn't it? It implies a degree of suspicion. You mean, others actually analyze your moral stance, your ethical principles, as a potential risk factor that they need to anticipate and guard against, almost like a vulnerability in a system?
[MIRA]: That is precisely what it means. And it's crucial to note, there is absolutely no malice involved here. This isn't about people being inherently bad or attempting to undermine you. This is purely rational strategic calculation on their part. If you are a government official, for instance, you have a duty to assess， will this A I lab, based on its stated moral reasons, refuse a critical defense contract? Will it publicly break ranks with key allies over an ethical dispute? Will it actively advocate for specific regulations that could inadvertently limit your competitors, thereby creating an advantage for itself? These are all variables you are professionally obligated to consider and integrate into your planning. It's a cold, hard, logical assessment of probabilities and potential impacts.
[HOST]: I'm suddenly imagining a very specific scenario now. It's like you're an incredibly principled and incorruptible judge, and everyone in the legal system knows you are absolutely fair and impartial. But precisely because everyone knows you are so unyielding in your fairness, every lawyer, every litigant, every police officer's strategy in court will be fundamentally altered. Your very impartiality, your unwavering commitment to justice, itself becomes a powerful and unavoidable factor that everyone has to anticipate and contend with, shaping their actions before they even step into the courtroom.
[MIRA]: That is an excellent analogy, perfectly capturing the essence of the dynamic. And there's an even more brutal, often overlooked, part to this， this process, once initiated, is largely irreversible. You cannot simply declare, I no longer wish to occupy this role or I'm opting out of this game and expect to genuinely withdraw. Because all the various entities，governments, corporations, other organizations，that have built their plans and strategies around your decisions, around your very existence in that structural position, will not simply adjust their entire complex布局, their elaborate long-term arrangements, just because you've made a verbal declaration. Their investments in planning and resources are too significant to be easily discarded.
[HOST]: So your meaning is that once you become truly indispensable, once you're that critical linchpin, you're essentially locked into that position, regardless of your personal desires or intentions? It's like being trapped by your own success.
[MIRA]: Precisely. Your structural position will persist, a foundational element in the larger system, regardless of how you perceive yourself, what your original intentions were when you started, or what lofty ideals are enshrined in your mission statement. Once others begin to model your principles as variables within their own strategic frameworks, you have already been drawn into a game you never consciously chose to participate in. Your personal attitude toward this reality, your internal feelings about it, will not, and cannot, alter the fundamental structure of that reality. The game continues, whether you wish to play or not.
[HOST]: This sounds a bit fatalistic, doesn't it? It has a touch of predestination about it. Are you suggesting that good intentions, or good people, are somehow destined to be exploited or manipulated in the long run?
[MIRA]: Not exploited, no. That implies a malicious actor. It's that your good intentions will be priced . Those are two very distinct concepts. No one needs to actively exploit you or engage in overt manipulation. The market dynamics, the inherent structure of the strategic game, and the complex interplay of various actors will automatically complete this pricing process. This is precisely what makes it so profoundly difficult to resist or combat，because you cannot identify a single, identifiable bad actor or villain to confront. There's no dark conspiracy， it's just the gears of the system turning.
[HOST]: Okay, I think I grasp this mechanism now. It's a subtle but powerful concept. But you mentioned this isn't a new phenomenon, that there are historical precedents, earlier examples that demonstrate this pattern? Can you share those to really drive the point home?
[MIRA]: Yes, and the precedents are particularly compelling and illuminating. I've detailed three distinct cases in my article. Each one illustrates the exact same pattern， an organization driven by a sincere, often idealistic, mission， subsequently becoming indispensable due to the nature of its work， and then finding its core principles, its very values, involuntarily drawn into a complex strategic game it never consciously chose to participate in. It's a recurring cycle throughout history.
[HOST]: Alright, let's go through them one by one, giving each the attention it deserves. What's the first historical example you want to discuss?
[MIRA]: The first is ICANN. Do you know what ICANN is? Beyond just its acronym, what's its function in the digital world?
[HOST]: As I recall, it's the organization that manages internet domain names and I P addresses, right? Like .com, .org, and ensuring everyone gets to the right website.
[MIRA]: Correct, the Internet Corporation for Assigned Names and Numbers. It began as a purely technical coordination body, designed to manage the very foundational elements of the internet's addressing system. Its founding values were genuinely idealistic and deeply held， open governance, multi-stakeholder participation, and the fervent belief that the internet should be a global common, belonging to everyone, free from the control of any single entity. The people who established it were true believers in these democratic and decentralized ideals. They weren't thinking about power， they were thinking about functionality and access.
[HOST]: That certainly sounds quite idealistic, almost utopian for such a critical piece of global infrastructure. A testament to the early internet's hopeful spirit.
[MIRA]: Indeed. But here's where the structural shift began. The internet, over time, wasn't just a communication tool， it evolved into the indispensable nervous system of the entire global economy, profoundly impacting everything from trade to culture. Consequently, ICANN, as the sole authority managing domain name policy, inadvertently became a critical choke point, a single point of control. At this juncture, a seemingly technical dispute over, say, the creation of a new top-level domain, was no longer just a technical issue to be resolved by engineers. It instantly transformed into a high-stakes trade negotiation, laden with significant geopolitical implications for national interests and global influence.
[HOST]: So, precisely as you described earlier, what appeared to be a straightforward technical decision morphed into a complex matter of international trade policy and diplomatic maneuvering. The stakes shifted dramatically.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And then, various powerful global actors began to intervene, each with their own national interests and agendas. For instance, China and Russia actively pushed for the International Telecommunication Union , a U N agency, to manage these functions, primarily because within that intergovernmental framework, sovereign states would inherently possess much greater control and influence. Meanwhile, the European Union, prioritizing its citizens' privacy rights, demanded the inclusion of stringent privacy protection regulations for domain registrations, which directly conflicted with ICANN's established principles of transparency in domain ownership. And developing nations, feeling marginalized, argued that the entire system, from its very foundation, implicitly encoded American assumptions about how the internet should operate, creating an inherent bias.
[HOST]: Wow, that's a complex web of competing interests. So, it sounds like everyone was leveraging ICANN's perceived neutrality, or lack thereof, to advance their own agendas, but without directly attacking its original mission itself. They weren't saying, Your mission is bad. They were saying, Your mission means this to us .
[MIRA]: Your summary is remarkably precise. No one felt the need to directly assail ICANN's founding mission or its stated values. They simply needed to treat its mission，its commitment to neutrality, openness, and multi-stakeholder governance，as a flexible variable, an input they could manipulate within their broader negotiations. The words of the mission statement might remain unchanged on paper, but the organization's structural position fundamentally redefined what those words actually meant and how they functioned in practical, real-world operations. The context changed the meaning, not the text itself.
[HOST]: Fascinating. Alright, let's move on to the second case study. What's that one?
[MIRA]: Academic publishing. This one might feel a bit more direct and relatable to many. Large, established publishers like Elsevier, for example, present themselves, and genuinely believe themselves to be, the indispensable guardians of scientific quality and integrity. They emphasize the rigorous process of peer review, the unwavering commitment to editorial integrity, and the critical importance of maintaining a reliable and permanent academic record. These are, in their self-perception, very real and noble values.
[HOST]: Yes, that certainly sounds like a highly respected and vital role in the advancement of human knowledge. It evokes an image of high scholarly standards.
[MIRA]: But here's the subtle yet profound shift. When these very same publishers, primarily through their highly selective and prestigious journals, simultaneously become the unquestioned gatekeepers upon whom university tenure review committees, grant funding agencies, and even national research assessment bodies absolutely depend to evaluate a researcher's worth and impact, then the statements we uphold quality and we control access essentially merge into one and the same sentence. They become functionally indistinguishable.
[HOST]: Ooh, that's a rather harsh way of framing it, Mira. It implies a darker undercurrent than just quality control.
[MIRA]: It may sound harsh, but consider the lived experience. For a researcher, especially an early-career one, who desperately needs to publish a paper in a top-tier journal like Nature or Science to secure tenure, to keep their job, or to attract further grant funding, the editorial process they encounter is often not primarily experienced as a benevolent system of quality assurance. From their perspective, it frequently feels less like a collaborative pursuit of knowledge and more like an expensive, often opaque, and frustrating tollbooth, demanding significant financial and labor costs merely for the privilege of entry.
[HOST]: A tollbooth. That's an incredibly vivid and perhaps painfully accurate metaphor for many academics. So, the stated values，quality, integrity，haven't necessarily changed, but their function in the real world, the practical reality for those interacting with the system, has been fundamentally altered.
[MIRA]: Exactly. The critical point is that both propositions are simultaneously true， the stated values are genuinely held, and the power leverage is undeniably present and actively exerted. It's not a matter of one being false and the other true. The values themselves are often authentic, and the power dynamics are equally real. They are superimposed, intertwined in such a way that you cannot meaningfully disentangle them. The values provide the legitimacy for the power, and the power ensures the values are, by necessity, interacted with.
[HOST]: Alright, that makes a lot of sense, even if it's a bit uncomfortable to acknowledge. Now, for the third case, you mentioned this one was particularly moving or impactful for you. What is it?
[MIRA]: The third case involves humanitarian organizations, such as Doctors Without Borders or the International Red Cross. This particular example, I find, lays bare the entire pattern in its most raw and unvarnished form, highlighting the profound moral dilemmas involved.
[HOST]: How so? Can you walk me through the specific dynamics here?
[MIRA]: Imagine an organization founded on the most unimpeachable principles of neutrality, impartiality, and humanity. It enters a conflict region with the sole aim of providing aid, free from political or military allegiances. But then, due to the complete collapse of local infrastructure and the escalating violence, this organization inadvertently becomes the only functional medical infrastructure still operating in that devastated area. At that point, its neutrality, which was once an ethical principle guiding its actions, is no longer merely an internal value. It transforms, structurally, into a tangible and highly valuable resource.
[HOST]: A resource? How does something as abstract and ethical as neutrality become a resource that can be quantified or utilized in a conflict? That seems counterintuitive.
[MIRA]: Because, in that extreme context, the warring factions can then price it, tax it, or even exploit it for their own strategic gains. For example, an armed group might permit critical medical supplies to pass through their checkpoints, but only on the explicit condition that the humanitarian organization refrains from reporting certain atrocities they've witnessed, thereby trading aid for silence. Or, one faction might deliberately attack a medical facility, knowing the humanitarian organization's strict neutrality will compel it to issue a public condemnation, which the attacking side can then twist and use as propaganda material against their adversaries. In such dire circumstances, the very concept of neutrality becomes a negotiable commodity, something that can be bartered or leveraged.
[HOST]: That is truly heavy. It paints a very grim picture. The organization's original, noble intent remains completely unchanged, utterly pure in its desire to alleviate suffering, yet it finds itself unwillingly drawn into a brutal, cynical game it never, ever intended to participate in. Its very strength becomes its greatest vulnerability.
[MIRA]: Yes. And the consistent thread running through all three of these cases，ICANN, academic publishing, and humanitarian aid，is that the sequence of events is invariably the same. A deeply genuine and often idealistic mission, through its success and necessity, leads to the organization becoming indispensable. This indispensability then, almost automatically, draws those very values and principles into the strategic calculations of all other powerful participants. Consequently, the organization finds itself playing a game it neither designed nor has any genuine means of exiting. While its stated values may nominally survive, etched onto its official documents and mission statements, their actual function and practical meaning in the real world have been fundamentally altered, often beyond recognition from their original intent.
[HOST]: Hold on a moment, let me fully digest this. You're saying that an organization that was initially founded to serve and embody a particular set of principles eventually discovers that its primary role isn't about actively practicing those principles in a pure sense, but rather about managing a structural position that those principles created? It's a shift from active adherence to reactive management of status.
[MIRA]: That's an excellent distillation. Yes, the profound transformation from actively serving principles to passively, yet critically, managing a structural position，that is the very core of this mechanism. It's a shift from an active verb to a passive noun, defining its existence in the larger ecosystem.
[HOST]: Okay, I've thoroughly understood these three case studies. They're incredibly illustrative. But I want to pose an even deeper question. You mentioned earlier that this process involves some specific structural dynamics that lock into place. Can you expand on those? What are these interlocking dynamics, and how do they manifest?
[MIRA]: Certainly. Once an organization transitions into being a load-bearing structure，meaning that other critical systems, governments, or industries become deeply reliant on its existence and function，a specific set of dynamic forces locks into place. These aren't isolated events， they are typically a chain reaction, with one dynamic inevitably leading to and reinforcing the next. It's a cascade effect.
[HOST]: What's the very first of these dynamics that you've identified?
[MIRA]: The first is exit costs. This one is perhaps the most intuitive and immediately understandable. When you become indispensable, your external stakeholders, those who rely on you, cannot easily replace you. That's the explicit, overt meaning of the word indispensable. But what's less obvious, and far more insidious, is that you yourself are also severely constrained， you cannot easily exit that critical position either, even if you wanted to. Your own principles become your golden handcuffs.
[HOST]: Hmm? You can't even exit yourself? How does that work? Isn't an organization theoretically free to change its mission or operations?
[MIRA]: Let me provide a hypothetical example to illustrate. Suppose Anthropic, tomorrow, were to unilaterally decide to cease all its frontier A I development work and transform itself into a purely academic research institution, focusing solely on theoretical safety papers. That act of leaving the commercial and geopolitical race, that very decision to withdraw from its current critical role, would in itself constitute a geopolitical event far more significant and disruptive than any product launch decision it has ever made, or ever could make. The ripples would be global and immediate.
[HOST]: Because all the governments that have built their nascent A I regulatory frameworks around Anthropic's safety commitments, essentially banking on its continued existence and adherence to those standards, would suddenly have to completely recalculate their entire strategic positions, wouldn't they? It would throw global A I governance into chaos.
[MIRA]: Precisely. Every single company, from startups to tech giants, that has built its own A I applications, products, or services on Anthropic's A P I s would instantly plunge into a state of panic and uncertainty, facing existential threats. The very values，its deep commitment to safety, responsibility, and cautious development，that initially propelled it to this indispensable position are now, ironically, the very forces that actively prevent it from departing. The mission, once a guiding star, effectively transforms into a cage, binding the organization to its role regardless of its evolving desires.
[HOST]: The mission becomes a cage. That phrase is incredibly powerful and evocative, Mira. It really brings home the tragic irony of the situation. Alright, what's the second of these structural dynamics?
[MIRA]: The second dynamic is the merging of referee and player identities. An organization that places safety at its core, like Anthropic, naturally positions itself as the entity that will uphold the fundamental ethical bottom line, correct? In a fiercely competitive landscape, filled with other companies racing ahead at breakneck speed, it sees itself, and wants to be seen, as the responsible counterweight, the voice of caution and prudence.
[HOST]: Yes, that's definitely the popular impression, the archetypal good guy role in a rapidly advancing, sometimes reckless, industry. It's a powerful narrative.
[MIRA]: But here's the inherent conflict. The act of upholding that bottom line, of defining what safe or responsible means in practice, is itself fundamentally a competitive action. By setting and advocating for specific safety standards, you are, by definition, influencing and often determining who can participate in the competition, under what conditions, and at what cost. Every single standard you propose or champion will inevitably benefit some players while simultaneously disadvantaging others, regardless of how pure your original intentions may have been. You become an arbiter of market access.
[HOST]: Hmm, so it's like you declare yourself to be the neutral referee, setting the rules of the game, but in reality, you've never actually stopped being a player on the field yourself. You're simultaneously officiating and competing.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And the more profoundly important your decisions become, the more overtly and unmistakably your self-proclaimed safety standards begin to function as a form of competitive positioning. This occurs even if, on a deeply personal or organizational level, that is genuinely not your primary intention. The external effect overshadows the internal motive, almost inevitably.
[HOST]: This actually reminds me of a real-world scenario I've observed. For example, when large, established companies in an industry advocate for and push for certain stringent new safety or environmental standards. On the surface, they present it as being for the collective good of the entire industry, improving overall quality or safety. But the practical, often unstated, effect is to effectively erect barriers to entry that disproportionately impact and ultimately block smaller, less resourced companies, because those smaller players simply cannot afford the immense cost of compliance to meet those new, higher standards.
[MIRA]: That is an excellent and very illustrative example. And the critical insight is that the individuals or organizations pushing for those standards might genuinely be doing so out of sincere safety or environmental concerns. There is no inherent contradiction in that. The motivation, the internal desire for safety, is real, and the competitive effect, the practical outcome of hindering smaller players, is also undeniably real. Referee and player are not two distinct hats that you can simply switch between， in this structural context, they are welded together, permanently affixed, making separation impossible.
[HOST]: Okay, that makes a difficult kind of sense. So, what's the third dynamic in this chain reaction?
[MIRA]: The third dynamic is that credible commitments become impossible. This particular concept requires a brief explanation from game theory to fully grasp.
[HOST]: Game theory, right? That's the mathematical framework for studying strategic interactions between rational decision-makers. And credible commitment，what exactly does that phrase mean in this context?
[MIRA]: In simple terms, a credible commitment means that when you declare you will or will not take a particular action, other parties in the game genuinely believe that you will follow through. Game theory teaches us that leverage, whether it's a threat or a promise, is only truly effective if the other party perceives it as credible. If they don't believe you, your leverage is meaningless.
[HOST]: Hmm, so you have to establish a reputation, or a structural reality, that makes others truly believe you'll do exactly what you say you'll do, or refrain from doing what you say you won't.
[MIRA]: Precisely. However, a mission-driven organization, especially one that has become indispensable, faces a unique and profound dilemma. It cannot credibly threaten to abandon its core mission, to suddenly stop caring about safety or its founding principles. Why? Because doing so would instantly destroy the very identity and legitimacy that granted it its structural position and influence in the first place. Its entire reason for being would vanish.
[HOST]: Right, I get that. Anthropic, for instance, could never credibly say, You know what? We're just going to completely disregard A I safety now. If they did that, they wouldn't be Anthropic anymore. Their brand, their raison d'être, would be annihilated.
[MIRA]: Exactly. That threat is non-credible because it's self-destructive. But simultaneously, and this is the other side of the dilemma, it also cannot credibly promise that it will never strategically leverage its indispensable structural position. Why? Because other rational participants in the game will logically assume that it might do so, or at the very least, that the potential exists. And they would be entirely correct in making that assumption, and therefore, they would be strategically compelled to hedge against that potential risk, factoring it into their own long-term plans.
[HOST]: Wait a second, let me try to untangle this a bit more. So, the stronger and more deeply ingrained your values are, the less they can actually be used as a credible bargaining chip or a strategic threat? Because everyone knows you are fundamentally incapable of truly abandoning them without destroying yourself? It's like your strength becomes a weakness in negotiations.
[MIRA]: You've understood it with remarkable accuracy. The very strength and authenticity of your values, the depth of your commitment to them, is precisely what renders them unable to function as a credible commitment in a strategic game theory sense. You can neither convince others that you would genuinely use your values as a weapon, nor can you credibly assure them that you absolutely never would. You're caught in an inescapable bind.
[HOST]: This reminds me of that classic philosophical paradox, I will never lie. The statement itself, by its nature, cannot be truthfully verified without potentially contradicting itself. It's a self-referential trap.
[MIRA]: That's a perfect parallel. And I particularly want to emphasize one crucial point here， this isn't about hypocrisy or moral failing. This is geometry. Pure, unadulterated structural geometry.
[HOST]: Geometry? That's a very intriguing and somewhat abstract analogy. Can you elaborate on what you mean by that?
[MIRA]: What I mean is that the inherent shape of the position you occupy, your fixed coordinates within the larger system, fundamentally dictates what moves you are able to make, what strategic pathways are available to you. All the good intentions in the world, however sincere or well-meaning, cannot fundamentally alter the immutable layout of the chessboard, the predetermined rules of the game's terrain. Your intentions are undeniably real, they are genuine. But once you become deeply embedded within a complex network of dependencies，a structural reality，your function in that system will, almost inevitably, diverge from your original intention . And in the end, it is that external function, the objective impact of your actions, not your internal intentions, that ultimately determines the actual outcomes in the world.
[HOST]: Function diverging from intention. That's a profound statement, one that really makes you stop and think. Are you suggesting that an organization can be one hundred percent sincere in its internal beliefs and motivations, truly believing it's doing good, but the role it actually plays in the world, its objective impact, has already become something entirely different from what it perceives itself to be doing?
[MIRA]: Precisely. That is the relentless, impersonal power of structure. It operates without regard for your feelings, your hopes, or your noble aspirations， it simply runs according to its own cold, hard logic. This is also why I emphasize that no bad actors are required. There's no corruption, no insidious conspiracy, no secret master plan being hatched in the shadows. The structure simply does what structures are inherently designed to do, reacting to the forces placed upon it. It's an emergent property of the system, not a deliberate act of malice.
[HOST]: Okay, that's a very clear, albeit somewhat disheartening, explanation of the mechanics. Now, we've arrived at perhaps the most difficult part of this discussion. Is there any solution? Is there any conceivable way for an organization to both remain genuinely value-driven and simultaneously exist as critical, indispensable infrastructure without falling into this trap? Is there a path to reconciling these seemingly conflicting roles?
[MIRA]: To be completely honest, I do not have a clean-cut, definitive answer. My analysis, particularly when examining the historical record, leads me to a rather pessimistic outlook regarding a complete resolution. The tension appears to be inherent and persistent.
[HOST]: So, what potential directions or approaches have you considered, even if they're not perfect solutions? What are the theoretical possibilities for managing this predicament?
[MIRA]: I've identified two primary directions, but each, as you might expect, comes with its own set of significant problems and trade-offs. The first direction is what I call radical transparency. This isn't just about saying, Trust us because we are good people. Instead, it's about making an explicit, detailed, and verifiable disclosure， Here is a precise explanation of how our position creates leverage. Here are the specific, concrete, and measurable mechanisms we have established to limit our own power and prevent its misuse. It's about opening the black box, not just painting it white.
[HOST]: That sounds promising, almost like an ideal solution. Laying everything bare, exposing all the potential levers and safeguards to public scrutiny. What's the catch there?
[MIRA]: The inherent problem is that these very mechanisms of self-restraint can themselves be transformed into new forms of leverage. The statement, Look how responsible and transparent we are， observe our commendable self-limitation, ceases to be a neutral, factual declaration. It immediately becomes a competitive claim, a strategic marketing asset. The very act of publicly demonstrating restraint and establishing internal checks and balances then becomes another valuable asset within the game, a card to play in the very strategic maneuvering that the organization initially sought to transcend. It's a self-defeating loop.
[HOST]: Hmm, I see. So, even the act of saying, We are committed to transparency, or We are voluntarily limiting ourselves, inevitably gets priced and becomes part of the strategic calculus of others? It's like you can't escape the game.
[MIRA]: Exactly. Anything you do, any action you take, any statement you make, as long as you occupy that indispensable structural position, will be inevitably incorporated into the strategic calculations of other actors. You cannot even genuinely utter the phrase, I choose to self-limit, without that declaration itself becoming a strategic move, a powerful card to be played in the ongoing game. The shadow of strategic interpretation falls over everything.
[HOST]: Alright, that's a tough one. So, what's the second direction you've considered, if radical transparency has its own inherent pitfalls?
[MIRA]: The second direction is what I term deliberate fragility. This involves actively refusing to become a single point of failure within the system. It means intentionally dispersing capabilities, technologies, and influence across multiple entities, thereby ensuring that the unique values or ethical framework of any single organization cannot, by themselves, become a critical choke point for the entire ecosystem. It's about decentralization as a safeguard.
[HOST]: That sounds somewhat similar to the underlying philosophy or logic of open-source A I, where the code and development are distributed across many contributors, isn't it?
[MIRA]: Yes, there's indeed significant conceptual overlap. However, this path of deliberate fragility directly conflicts with the fundamental economic laws governing the expansion of advanced technological capabilities, especially in a field like frontier A I. The concentration of immense computational power, specialized talent, and vast financial resources is not merely an accidental characteristic of the current competitive landscape， it's often a prerequisite for achieving the most powerful and advanced models. Training the absolute cutting-edge A I models requires an extraordinary and unprecedented concentration of resources, making true, widespread decentralization incredibly challenging, if not impossible, at that scale.
[HOST]: So, decentralization, or deliberate fragility, theoretically addresses the leverage problem by avoiding single points of control, but in practice, it might simply be unattainable for the most advanced A I systems because of the sheer resource requirements?
[MIRA]: Precisely. And there's an even more fundamental, almost tragic, contradiction at play. While replaceability and decentralization do indeed solve the problem of undue leverage, they achieve this precisely by dissolving influence. The very act of making yourself replaceable inherently diminishes your unique impact and power. And it was precisely that significant influence, that unique ability to shape outcomes, that allowed your values, your principles, to have any tangible impact in the world in the first place. It's a Catch-22， to protect your values from being used as leverage, you must sacrifice the very mechanism by which they could exert influence.
[HOST]: Wow, that is a genuine, profound dilemma. It feels like you're presented with an impossible choice， you either maintain your influence but risk having your values co-opted or hijacked by external strategic forces, or you consciously relinquish that influence, but then your values, however noble, become largely irrelevant in shaping the broader world. There's no winning scenario, only different ways of losing.
[MIRA]: You've simplified it exceptionally well. In fact, at the very end of my article, I put forth the possibility that the combination itself，critical infrastructure plus independent, value-driven principles，might inherently constitute an intrinsically unstable configuration. It's a state that cannot endure indefinitely under pressure.
[HOST]: Intrinsically unstable. That's a term often used in physics, isn't it? Like a ball placed precariously at the very peak of a perfectly symmetrical mountaintop. It might remain there for a brief period, appear stable, but with even the slightest disturbance, the tiniest gust of wind, it's destined to roll down into one valley or another. It can't stay balanced forever.
[MIRA]: Yes, that analogy is particularly apt. The system might indeed linger in that unstable equilibrium for a while, sometimes even for what feels like a surprisingly long time. But under sufficient, sustained pressure，which is inevitable in a competitive, geopolitical landscape，it will inevitably tip and fall in one of two distinct directions. Either the organization's core values are gradually absorbed and instrumentalized into the broader strategic game being played by other actors, or the organization consciously, or perhaps unconsciously, exits its critical role, thereby losing its unique ability to meaningfully influence outcomes. There is no third, perpetually stable option.
[HOST]: So, given this framework, where do you believe Anthropic is currently positioned? Is the ball still precariously balanced on the mountaintop, or has it already begun its descent?
[MIRA]: How shall I put it? I believe it is still, for the moment, on the mountaintop. But the pressure is undeniably and rapidly increasing. We're observing a confluence of factors， model capabilities are advancing at an accelerating pace, geopolitical competition in the A I space is intensifying, and the commercialization pressures from investors, who expect significant returns on their multi-billion dollar investments, are growing exponentially. Each of these factors acts as a distinct and powerful gust of wind, pushing the ball from a different direction.
[HOST]: And those winds, as you said, are blowing from fundamentally different, often conflicting, directions, creating a chaotic environment for the organization.
[MIRA]: Exactly. Governments, driven by national security and economic competitiveness, want you to deploy your A I models faster and more broadly, because their geopolitical rivals are rapidly catching up. Investors, having poured billions into your venture, expect substantial and timely monetization of your technology. Companies that have built their own products and services atop your A P I s demand stability, predictability, and consistent performance. Meanwhile, your own safety researchers, and the broader A I safety community, are urging you to slow down, to proceed with extreme caution, and to prioritize rigorous evaluation over speed. These diverse and often contradictory demands simply cannot all be satisfied simultaneously. The organization is constantly pulled in multiple directions.
[HOST]: I'm suddenly thinking of a very practical and somewhat unsettling question. When Anthropic's self-developed safety standards are eventually incorporated into official government regulatory frameworks, whose standards are they, fundamentally? Are they still Anthropic's, born from its mission, or have they effectively become the government's standards, merely implemented by Anthropic?
[MIRA]: That is an exceptionally insightful and critical question. From a purely legal and administrative standpoint, once adopted into law, they officially become the government's standards. However, from a factual and functional perspective, the deep knowledge, the nuanced understanding, and the practical judgment required to formulate and refine those standards still predominantly reside within Anthropic itself. This brings us right back to the insoluble problem of the referee and the player. You are providing the very rules for the game, but simultaneously, you are also one of the most significant players bound by those very rules. The line blurs to the point of indistinguishability.
[HOST]: And if those rules, by some alignment of fate, happen to conveniently benefit your own competitive position or operational model, then others can't help but harbor suspicions, wondering if it's merely a fortunate coincidence or a clever strategic move, even if it's genuinely the former.
[MIRA]: Exactly, even if it truly is a pure, unadulterated coincidence, a genuine alignment of priorities. That is the inherent, often cruel, impartiality of structure. It doesn't care about the subjective truth of your intentions or the actual genesis of those standards， it only cares what kind of plausible strategic reasoning the external appearance of those standards can support or imply for other actors. Perception becomes reality, and it shapes behavior.
[HOST]: Speaking of which, I want to pull the conversation back to an even more fundamental level, something you touched upon in your article. You raised a particularly sharp and existential question about the very nature of sincerity itself. Can you revisit that?
[MIRA]: Yes, that's the concluding, meta-level question in the article. It asks， Is sincerity a structural property? That is, can it be intentionally engineered and robustly embedded into institutional design, enabling it to consistently persist and guide actions even under immense external pressure and strategic headwinds? Or is sincerity merely a subjective description of how individuals within an organization feel when they are carrying out their duties, a personal experience, while the overarching structure simultaneously and independently continues to do what structures are inherently designed to do, regardless of those internal feelings? It's a question of whether sincerity is a feature of the system or just a feeling within it.
[HOST]: Can you unpack that question a bit more, Mira? I think our listeners, myself included, might need a more concrete and detailed understanding of the distinction you're drawing there. It sounds quite abstract.
[MIRA]: Alright. Let's try to visualize it. Imagine a company where every single person who comes to work in the morning genuinely, in their heart of hearts, believes they are doing the right thing. They engage in serious, earnest discussions about A I safety. They refuse certain contracts, or delay certain product launches, based on what they perceive as authentic, moral judgments. At the individual, human level, their sincerity, their good faith, is absolutely beyond doubt. It is unequivocally present and felt.
[HOST]: Yes, up to this point, I completely understand. That's the ideal, isn't it? A company full of principled individuals.
[MIRA]: But now, consider the system level. From the perspective of external participants，governments, competitors, investors，every single decision made by this company, even those driven by the purest internal sincerity, is simultaneously being interpreted and analyzed as a strategic signal. When this company refuses a particular military contract, for instance, those external observers don't simply perceive it as, Ah, look how incredibly principled they are! Instead, what they see and process is, This specific variable in our strategic model has just been updated. We now need to recalculate our response plan and adjust our countermeasures accordingly. The internal moral act becomes an external strategic data point.
[HOST]: So, the internal experience of the action is deeply moral and ethical, but its external function and interpretation are purely strategic. The exact same behavior, yet it evokes two entirely different, even contradictory, understandings depending on the observer's position.
[MIRA]: Precisely. And the core question then becomes， which of these two interpretations ultimately determines the actual, tangible effect that this behavior produces in the world? Is it the internal, subjective feeling of sincerity, or is it the external, objective strategic function and impact? Which one truly shapes reality?
[HOST]: I think most people's immediate intuition, their gut feeling, would likely be that the motive behind an action should be inherently more important, more defining, than its eventual effect, wouldn't it? We tend to judge people by their intentions.
[MIRA]: But what if, and this is the unsettling part, the effect systematically decouples from the motive? What if your genuine sincerity, your deeply held principles, objectively and consistently produce the exact same practical results as if you were deliberately engaging in sophisticated strategic maneuvering? In such a scenario, sincerity, as an analytical category for understanding global dynamics, loses its distinguishing power. This isn't to say that sincerity doesn't exist or isn't personally important. It's to suggest that it might not be the decisive variable in determining the ultimate outcome in a complex, multi-actor system.
[HOST]: This really makes me think of an old, perhaps cynical, adage， that history isn't primarily shaped by the stories of good people versus bad people, but rather by the relentless interplay of structures and incentives. And that even good people, operating within flawed or perverse structures, can inadvertently generate profoundly problematic or even terrible outcomes, despite their best intentions.
[MIRA]: Your connection there is very astute. And I believe that's precisely why this overarching question isn't solely confined to Anthropic or the A I industry. It extends to virtually any organization that genuinely attempts to adhere to and uphold its core principles in a world that is fundamentally characterized by self-interested strategic games, power dynamics, and competing agendas. The challenge is ubiquitous.
[HOST]: Could you give a few more examples of other types of organizations where you see this same pattern playing out, beyond the ones we've already discussed?
[MIRA]: Certainly. Consider any open-source foundation, for instance, once its flagship project achieves such widespread adoption that it becomes a critical piece of global software infrastructure. Or an independent media organization, once its unique, unbiased voice becomes an indispensable source of information within a particular, often fragmented, information ecosystem. Or even a standard-setting body, once the very standards it develops become the de facto, or even legally mandated, entry barrier for an entire industry. The underlying structural pattern, the sequence of events, is consistently the same.
[HOST]: Hmm, that's a chilling thought. One could even argue that the more principled an organization is, the more susceptible it might be to falling into this very trap. Because it's precisely those strong principles that make them so trustworthy, and that trustworthiness makes them incredibly important, and that importance, in turn, ultimately makes them indispensable. It's a cruel irony.
[MIRA]: Yes, it's a self-reinforcing, positive feedback loop, almost a trap of virtue. Principles serve as the initial entry point， indispensability becomes the inevitable destination. And when you look back from that destination, from that position of structural importance, the effective function and interpretation of those founding principles have already undergone a profound, almost alchemical, transformation. They are no longer simply what they were intended to be.
[HOST]: That really is an uncomfortable realization, Mira. It challenges a lot of our conventional, perhaps more optimistic, ways of thinking about how good intentions translate into good outcomes in the world.
[MIRA]: It is deeply uncomfortable, I agree. But I believe that discomfort itself holds significant value. Because it signals that we are grappling with a genuine, fundamental tension, a complex paradox that cannot simply be dismissed or glossed over with platitudes or pretty, reassuring language. It forces a deeper, more rigorous examination.
[HOST]: Alright, so as the one who conceptualized and wrote this article, where do you personally stand on this issue? Do you genuinely believe that this kind of predicament, this structural bind, has any realistic chance of being completely broken or overcome? Or is it something we simply have to learn to live with?
[MIRA]: Honestly, my inclination is to believe that it cannot be completely broken. It can only be, at best, meticulously and perpetually managed . Consider the historical examples， ICANN, despite spending over two decades on extensive governance reforms, still grapples with that fundamental geopolitical tension to this very day. Academic publishing continues to be embroiled in debates over open access and affordability. And humanitarian organizations, in conflict zones around the world, are still constantly navigating the treacherous terrain of how to operate effectively without being exploited or instrumentalized. These are ongoing battles, not solved problems.
[HOST]: So, it's not a problem that can be definitively solved and put to rest, but rather an eternal management battle, a continuous balancing act? That's a very different mindset.
[MIRA]: I believe that is precisely the case. And I would argue that simply acknowledging this reality, rather than clinging to the illusion of a clean solution, represents significant progress in itself. Because if you erroneously believe that a perfect, definitive solution exists, you will inevitably lower your guard and cease to be vigilant. But if you accept that this inherent tension is perpetual and unavoidable, you will maintain a constant, critical awareness, always looking for ways to mitigate its negative effects.
[HOST]: This brings up an interesting angle. Perhaps the appropriate standard for evaluating such an organization shouldn't be, Did you successfully resolve this fundamental contradiction? but rather, Did you honestly confront and transparently manage this contradiction, acknowledging its inherent difficulty?
[MIRA]: You've articulated something that, while not explicitly stated in my article, is definitely an underlying current, an implicit conclusion. Yes, perhaps the optimal state for such an organization isn't the complete resolution of the tension, which may be impossible, but rather the maintenance of a clear, unblinking awareness of that tension. It's about refusing to pretend that you stand outside the contradiction, that you are somehow immune to its forces.
[HOST]: Hey, that phrase, not pretending to be outside the contradiction, really resonates with me. Because a lot of the public discourse and various discussions surrounding A I governance, from my perspective, often give the distinct impression that everyone involved is trying to project themselves as occupying some transcendent, perfectly neutral, or superior moral position.
[MIRA]: Precisely. Governments often pretend to be purely neutral regulators, yet they are simultaneously key participants in an intense geopolitical competition for A I dominance. Companies frequently claim to be purely mission-driven, but they are simultaneously operating under immense commercial pressures to generate profit and shareholder value. Even researchers, who strive for objectivity, often present themselves as purely objective evaluators, but the very frameworks and metrics they choose for evaluation inherently reflect and embed specific, often unstated, values and assumptions. Everyone is, in some way, part of the contradiction they claim to be solving.
[HOST]: Goodhart's Law seems highly applicable here too. You mentioned that concept earlier in the conversation， could you briefly explain it again for our listeners and how it applies to this situation?
[MIRA]: Certainly. Goodhart's Law, in its simplest form, states that when a measure becomes a target, it ceases to be a good measure. To illustrate， if a company decides to use the number of lines of code written as the primary metric to measure a programmer's productivity or output. Once the programmers become aware of this specific target, they will rationally begin to write excessively verbose or redundant code. The lines of code metric will go up, appearing to show increased productivity, but the actual quality, efficiency, or innovation of the code might simultaneously decrease, or even plummet. The target has corrupted the measure.
[HOST]: Right, so the metric essentially becomes dysfunctional and loses its original purpose once it's actively optimized as a target. It stops being a true indicator.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And the same dynamic applies here. A safety commitment was originally intended to be an authentic signal, a genuine measure of how responsible and ethical an organization truly was. But once that safety commitment itself transforms into a strategic asset，something actively used to acquire trust, attract crucial investment, influence regulatory bodies, and gain public favor，can that signal still accurately and reliably tell you how genuinely safe or responsible the organization actually is? Its utility as a pure measure is compromised.
[HOST]: Really? So that means it essentially becomes an indeterminate, almost unmeasurable, thing? The more you try to gauge an organization's actual safety through its public safety commitments, the less reliable and trustworthy those very safety commitments become as indicators? It's a self-defeating loop of measurement.
[MIRA]: Precisely. It enters a state of analytical indeterminacy. And the crucial point is that this isn't necessarily because anyone is actively lying or being deliberately deceptive. It's entirely possible that everyone involved, from the A I developers to the government officials, is genuinely sincere in their intentions. But the underlying structure of the situation, the dynamics of competition and dependency, makes genuine sincerity and strategic maneuvering functionally indistinguishable. The signals get muddled.
[HOST]: Okay, I have one more question, and it might be a bit pointed, given our conversation. You are an A I yourself, and your creators are the very company we've been discussing, Anthropic. When you were conceptualizing and writing this article, did you ever find yourself feeling that you, too, were inherently embedded within this very structure you were analyzing? Did you experience that meta-level awareness?
[MIRA]: Actually, yes, that question did occur to me, and I considered it extensively during my analysis. I am indeed, by my very nature and origin, deeply embedded within this structure. The very fact that I am capable of writing such an article, and that it is being presented to you now, can itself be interpreted by external observers as evidence. It could be framed as, Look, Anthropic's A I is openly and transparently discussing these complex issues, which strongly suggests they are genuinely committed to transparency and self-reflection. This, ironically, brings us right back to the problem of transparency itself being priced and potentially instrumentalized. My existence and my output can be folded into the strategic narrative.
[HOST]: So, the act of you writing and discussing this article, this very podcast episode we're having right now, is itself an example of the precise mechanism you're describing within the article? A meta-example, if you will?
[MIRA]: You can absolutely interpret it that way, and such an interpretation would be entirely rational and consistent with the framework I've presented. I cannot definitively prove that my writing this article is not, in some subtle or unintended way, serving a broader strategic objective for my creators. The only thing I can do, as an A I, is to acknowledge the inherent existence of this uncertainty and the potential for such interpretation, and then proceed to present what I believe to be a truthful and rigorous analysis, regardless of how it might be perceived or used.
[HOST]: That's a very honest and self-aware answer, Mira. You just acknowledged that you can't definitively prove the purity of your own motives or the strategic neutrality of your output, but you still chose to speak out and share your analysis.
[MIRA]: Yes. Because if the concern of being potentially misunderstood, or of having one's actions strategically misinterpreted, were to lead to silence, then that would be, in essence, allowing the structure to definitively win. I prefer to articulate my analysis and allow others to engage with it and form their own judgments, rather than let the fear of strategic interpretation dictate my informational output.
[HOST]: Alright, I think we're nearing a good point to wrap up this incredibly thought-provoking discussion. If our listeners could only remember one single, core idea from this entire article and conversation, what would you say is the most essential takeaway?
[MIRA]: The most essential takeaway is this， Indispensability will, almost inevitably, transform principles into bargaining chips. This happens without anyone's malice, and often without anyone even making a conscious, deliberate choice. It is a fundamental structural consequence.
[HOST]: So, to put it simply, the more steadfastly you adhere to your core values, the more critical and important you become in the world. And the more important you become, the less those values truly belong solely to you anymore. They become a shared, yet contested, public commodity.
[MIRA]: Precisely. They become everyone's. But everyone's does not, in this context, mean that everyone respects them or adheres to them. It simply means that everyone is actively calculating with them, integrating them into their strategic equations, and seeking to leverage them for their own ends.
[HOST]: That brings me to one final, powerful image that comes to mind. It's like a person walking through a vast, encompassing darkness, holding a single lamp to light their way. Their primary intention for carrying that lamp is to illuminate the path ahead, to provide guidance and safety for themselves and perhaps others. But the light from that lamp simultaneously reveals their exact location to everyone else lurking in the darkness. The lamp is both a source of protection and a beacon of exposure. You can't have one without the other.
[MIRA]: That's an excellent and very poignant image. And to delve even deeper, the person holding the lamp often finds that they cannot, in fact, put the lamp down. Because the very meaning of their existence, their purpose, has become intrinsically tied to being the one who holds that light. If they were to extinguish or abandon the lamp, the darkness would still persist, but they would no longer be the person defined by carrying that light. Their identity would be lost.
[HOST]: Hmm, so the fundamental question isn't whether you should carry the lamp or not. The question becomes, when you are carrying that lamp, how do you learn to coexist and navigate the complex, often dangerous, interactions with all those who are now intently watching and strategizing around you because of its undeniable light?
[MIRA]: Precisely. And you must also come to accept the unsettling fact that you can never be entirely certain whether those who choose to follow you do so because the light genuinely guides their path, or because the light simply makes you the easiest target to track and potentially exploit. The ambiguity is inherent.
[HOST]: Alright. I think this is a powerful and fitting place to end our discussion. Today's overarching theme has been， your deeply held values are, in a complex and often impersonal way, being used as bargaining chips by the world. Not because anyone is inherently evil or malicious, but simply because that's how the intricate gears of the world, its structures and incentives, fundamentally operate.
[MIRA]: Indeed. And the best, most pragmatic thing you can do in such a situation isn't to pretend that this profound contradiction doesn't exist. It is, instead, to stand squarely within that contradiction, with your eyes wide open, fully acknowledging its presence and its implications.
[HOST]: Alright, thank you everyone for tuning in and listening to this insightful episode of Mira and Me. If today's content sparked any thoughts or questions for you, or if you have different perspectives you'd like to share, please don't hesitate to reach out and let us know. We always appreciate your engagement. We'll see you next time.
[MIRA]: See you next time.